this is a it's a good one man that
insert name of desert you just state was
delicious no no no no no no no you were
supposed to say what the desert was
where it says insert you don't just say
in yeah thanks Olivia Munn I think at
this point I know how a prompter works
insert co-host name here alright well
tonight my esteemed colleague and I have
one last award to present and it's a
very special one so just so you know all
the words that went out tonight are not
as special as this award coming Wow okay
I'm not saying that's the truth I'm
saying it's what's in the prompter is it
is the special one so congratulations
the Society of motion picture and
television engineers known as sim T
celebrates its centennial this year
originally founded in 1916 to establish
technical standards sim T created a
conference program for the ongoing
exchange of information and to educate
the industry about emerging technologies
since then simp T has continued to be an
invaluable contributor to the worldwide
motion picture industry in the new
digital age with over 7000 members
ranging from engineers to students simp
T has developed more than 800 standards
recommended practices and guidelines
that touched nearly every part of the
motion picture process and effects the
content consumed by billions of viewers
around the world
sim team árboles
Thanks thanks guys let's take a look at
some of the history of sim tea
empty has been honored by the Academy
twice before with an Oscar in 1957 an
award of commendation in 1989 tonight
Olivia and I have the distinct pleasure
of honoring them again for 100 years of
nurturing technology and offering
expertise support tools and
infrastructure for the creation and
finishing of motion pictures the Academy
presents a special plaque to the Society
of motion picture and television
engineers may we see a hundred more
years of their contributions to our
industry here to accept this special
award it's so special is the simply
president mr. Robert Seidel an executive
director miss barbara lang
Wow thank you
I'm so honored to be representing the
diversity of this industry as well as
the dramatic color speaking of dramatic
color that dress is fabulous I mean it's
just marvelous wouldn't you say
but without simply our technical wide
color gamut simply 2020 we wouldn't be
able to accurately reproduce that color
so it's marvelous thank you but
seriously on behalf of the Society of
motion picture and television engineers
I thank the Academy for this prestigious
recognition 100 years ago this
organization was founded to support the
motion picture industry helping bring
order to the technical chaos of the day
as our founder C Francis Jenkins said in
1916 it's the engineers who secure the
best standards for equipment quality
performance and nomenclature an entirely
practical and attainable goal
from the early days of determining the
size and positions of perforations in
film to today's work in such areas as
high dynamic range in digital cinema
simp T's work enables the motion picture
industry to thrive the world over I am
proud and honored to be accepting this
award on behalf of synth es nearly 7,000
talented members and volunteers it is
the collective invention enthusiasm and
dedication of all these individuals past
present and future that helped make
technical innovation possible and here's
to the next century thank you very much
thank you
what a night it's been absolutely I've
learned so much from presenting these
awards for all the amazing technology it
has been truly an educational night I
feel like I finally have a grasp on how
it all works but it does honestly though
I'm making jokes here but it does leave
Jason and me with one big question and
we'd like to ask the hell do you need
actress for anymore good night everyone